The equations below all define
the same polynomial function,
f of x.
So they've just written
f of x in different ways.
Here they've fully factored
f of x out as negative 4,
times x minus 3,
times x minus 2, times
x plus 1, times x plus 5.
Then here, it looks like
they factored it once,
and then they factored
it into two quadratics,
and then they
completed the square
for each of those quadratics.
And then here, this
is just factoring it
into two quadratic expressions.
And then here, this is the
thing just fully expanded out,
multiplied out as a polynomial.
Which form of f of
x is most useful
for determining end behavior?
So when we think
about end behavior,
we really want to focus on
the highest degree term.
We really want to focus on
this term right over here,
because as x becomes
very, very, very positive,
this term is going to dominate.
And as x becomes very,
very, very negative,
this term is going to dominate.
And so this term is
really going to describe
what the end behavior is.
We can even think about
the end behavior here.
We have an even
exponent, so it's
going to have behavior
like x squared,
which is just another way of
saying that as x gets positive,
the function is going to
get positive, very positive.
And as x becomes very
negative, the function
is going to become
very positive,
because it's an even exponent.
And the fact that there's a
negative coefficient in front
of this highest
degree x term, this
tells us it's going to
be similar to the shape
of negative x squared.
It's going to be
downward opening
if you were to think
about its end behavior.
So which form of the
function is most useful?
Definitely D, the
expanded out version.
So I'll go with D.
So like the equation below, it's
similar end behavior f of x.
We already talked about it.
It's an even exponent, or it's
an even degree, we could say.
And then we have a negative
out in front of it.
So it's going to have
similar end behavior to y
is equal to negative x squared.
And then they say,
which form of f of x
is most useful for
finding zeroes?
When we're finding
zeroes, we're trying
to find the x values that would
make the function equal to 0.
And this first form
right over here
where we're all factored
out-- that's the most useful
for finding 0s.
We know that if we wanted to
set this whole thing to be
equal to 0-- we said, hey,
when does this equal 0?
That means that one of these
expressions-- at least one
of these expressions
need to be equal 0.
We can independently
set them equal to 0
and then solve for x.
So, this would be 0 when x is
equal to 3, x is equal to 2,
x is negative 1,
and x is negative 5.
So A, Is definitely the
most useful for finding 0s.